sziasztok egy rendhagyó epizóddal
készültem úgy döntöttem hogy megosztom
veletek azokat a kincseket amiket az
elmúlt egy évben a chat gpt-vel
kapcsolatban és más ai chatekkel
kapcsolatban szereztem tekintettel arra
hogy mint menedzser az én szakmai
életemnek a teljesítményét körülbelül
megháromszorozta úgy éreztem hogy nagyon
fontos lenne beszélgetni azokról a
tippekről technikákról amelyeket én
hasznosnak tartottam gyertek
csatlakozzatok hallgassátok meg ezt az
epizódot gondolkozzunk arról hogy hogyan
lehet ezt a technológiát együtt
használni nem pedig az áldozatává válni